si tu étais un défaut tu serais quoi
j'étais un défaut ouais l'envi une envie
d'aller assouvi un peu ton enviée là ça
va non pas encore je vais très très star
une injure ça je sais pas incapable un
cadavre d'un sur six mouvements on
ajoute celle de nietzsche qui sait
donner à l'autre la honte de soi c'est
la pire chose tu le fais deux fois quand
tu servait à saint tropez de légende de
toile ces sacs pour ça que tu leur
emploi et barclays et nettoyer ses
chemises tachées à la mousse au chocolat
santé et puis je comprends la prime
philippe 10 sec c'est important c'était
une infirmité
j'étais une infirmité autres incapable
d'aimer nation un assassin si j'étais
assez peut-être landru parce qu'il
aimait vraiment les flammes et une
guerre j'étais
les guerres 17 la guerre les sexes prix
je passe bien quand même j'ai toujours
il cette fille qui s'appelle marie
quitte équilibre ouais tu vas rester
longtemps avec les pumas petit à petit
coup j'ai trouvé ton chez toi d'être
béton verdunois trouver mari ça va
s'arranger
c'était une arme à double tranchant a
été fait pour garder une chance en or